si madame la présidente le lhc abandon
des leaders du bric site en refusant
d'affronter la situation qu'ils ont eux
mêmes créés en dit long sur les menaces
importantes qui pèsent désormais sur la
grande bretagne
mais je veux dire que des risques
importants menacent aussi ceux qui
restent risque de délitement
d'enlisement d'éclatement si nous ne
sommes pas capables de changer ce qui
doit l'être de prendre des initiatives
de repenser l'europe ses objectifs ses
règles et son fonctionnement
ce que les peuples européens attendent
c'est une vision c'est une perspective
et pas seulement celle du marché car on
ne donne pas sa vie au marché mais celle
d'une europe politique efficace utile
recentrer sur l'essentiel
celle d'une europe démocratique dans
laquelle les citoyens seront enfin
associé aux décisions qui se prennent en
leur nom c'est à cette prise de
conscience que j'appelle l'ensemble des
dirigeants européens avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
il y à vraiment urgence